[Musique]
nouvelle édition de l'entretien
politique sur tv 78 sur radio sensations
entretien politique entièrement consacré
à partir de maintenant aux différentes
élections que ce soit régionales ou
départementales aurore bergé bonjour
bonjour et merci de nous recevoir ici à
rambouillet dans votre permanence de
députés même si ce n'est pas en tant que
député qui nous venons voir aujourd'hui
vous êtes tête de liste avec jean-noël
barrot pourrait les yvelines sous la
candidature au niveau de la région de
laurent saint martin une liste donc
union lrm et modem déjà un mot sur cette
candidature parce que je les dis vous
êtes député déjà pourquoi cette
candidature aux régionales
je me suis posé en effet la question de
savoir si c'était bien que des
parlementaires s'engage pour se
consacrer à un autre mandat qui serait
celui de conseiller régional puisque
c'est avec des on ne pourrait pas
cumuler avec des fonctions exécutives au
sein de la région est tout simplement
parce qu'à une complémentarité ya ce que
l'état peut faire il ya ce que nous on
peut faire à l'assemblée
mais il ya aussi la gestion du quotidien
et le quotidien des franciliens ici dans
le sud yvelines
c'est aussi la question des mobilités et
ça c'est ile-de-france mobilité c'est la
question aussi de la lutte contre la
délinquance à l'est de plus en plus
mobiles c'est ce qu'on propose notamment
sur la lutte contre l'insécurité donc je
crois qu'il ya une vraie complémentarité
qu'on doit avoir entre l'état et les
collectivités et donc une poursuite
finalement de ce qu'on fait nous à
l'assemblée au niveau national et qui
doit être fait au niveau régional et
dans les yvelines
ensuite il va falloir faire passer le
message sur le terrain 11 % dans les
derniers sondages d'intentions de vote
pour votre candidat c'est loin derrière
valérie pécresse loin derrière le
rassemblement national également comment
vous allez inverser la tendance
déjà en étant présent sur le terrain en
faisant connaître notre candidature
c'est la candidature de la majorité
présidentielle de celles et ceux qui ont
aussi envie de soutenir le président de
la république est de démontrer que ce
qu'on a fait dans la gestion de la crise
la capacité qu'on a eu à protéger les
français quoi qu'il en coûte protéger
l'emploi protéger nos entreprises
protéger nos enfants aussi avec la
continuité pédagogique et bien c'est
aussi ça qu'on doit pouvoir déployer au
niveau de la région qu'on peut pas avoir
en permanence une région un état qui
serait adversaire alors qu'on doit jouer
collectif pendant la crise je crois que
ça c'est le premier message qui est
attendu de nous et puis aussi je crois
que les français pour l'instant ils sont
pas vraiment dans les élections peut pas
se mentir c'est dans deux mois c'est à
la fois très court pour nous mais c'est
très loin pour eux donc je crois que
plus on va entre
dans cette campagne puis on va voir les
compétences qui sont celles de la région
et il a nécessité d'avoir une région
forte et je crois plus ils
s'intéresseront à ce qu'on aura alors
dit on va parler de vos propositions
rapidement juste un mot justement vous
l'avez dit les français sont pas
forcément dans l'optique d'aller voter
d'une campagne électorale
vous ne craignez pas le vote sanction
non plus de ce qu'ils reprochent la
gestion de crise aussi au président
macron peut-être freya toujours mille
interprétations sur le vote moi c'est en
effet le risque de l'abstention qui est
extrêmement puissant cette année on a
déjà se souvient des élections
municipales où entrent évidemment le coc
vide et puis vous savez ces deux tours
qui étaient très éloignés l'un de
l'autre forcément ça n'avait pas non
plus aidé une forte participation
mais je crois que la région c'est
vraiment la gestion de notre quotidien
et donc c'est ça qui est en jeu c'est la
question des lycées c'est la question
des transports
c'est la question de notre sécurité au
quotidien et puis c'est aussi tout ce
que la région peut faire en plus pour
nous je pense notamment encore une fois
la question de la santé la question de
la sécurité la question de l'emploi et
donc c'est de ça qu'on a envie de porter
dans cette campagne aura un berger tête
de liste donc dans les yvelines avec
jean-noël barrot sur la liste de laurent
saint martin pour ces régionales
parlons de quelques-unes des
propositions déjà qu'ils ont été et qui
ont été présentés
le front populaire par exemple un euro
investi par un particulier ce sont 2
euros abondé par la région comment ça
fonctionnerait concrètement c'est se
dire qu'il faut que chacun en soit les
acteurs aussi de la relance et du
soutien à nos commerçants à nos artisans
à nos tpe à nos pme et franciliens dont
beaucoup étaient pendant la crise on a
vu qu'on avait une appétence l'envi de
faire travailler en local mais au delà
de faire travailler en local on sait qui
est des entreprises qui vont sortir
fragilisée de la crise pour des raisons
évidentes qu'il ya ce que l'état fait
fonds de solidarité l'activité partielle
les prêts garantis par l'état
il ya aussi ce que nous on peut faire
citoyen en liant demain avec la région
et donc l'idée c'est de dire ben écoutez
on peut même avec peu de moyens pas
soutenir notre libraire soutenir notre
artisan soutenir notre menu usées et
donc on peut investir quelques centaines
d'euros et jusqu'à 300 euros que vous
vous mettrez en tant que citoyen et bien
la région mettra autant de manière
encore une fois avoir on l'espère une
enveloppe globale de près de 600
millions d'euros d'investissements qui
seront directement fléchés vers celles
et ceux qui créent de l'emploi dans
notre pays et en ile de france notamment
encore une fois nos artisans et aux
commerçants donc la région elle est pas
là pour y avoir un gain le gain ce sera
le maintien de l'emploi la construction
de l'emploi et le soutien aux
entreprises
par contre ce sera un investissement
pour les franciliens qui sera garanti
qu'ils peuvent pas perdre
et puis on espère même évidemment que
comme ce seront des investissements
puissant et bien on puisse y gagner par
les emplois par l'on transporte aussi
vous êtes dans le sud yvelines la
question de la mobilité est aussi
importante pour ces territoires un peu
plus reculée en région ile de france et
il ya cette proposition d'aidé à l'achat
aussi de véhicules électriques par on le
voit bien de cette plus en plus
compliqué de se déplacer c'est le plus
en plus compliqué de venir à paris on
voit bien que les différentes mesures
qui ont été prises par la maire de paris
sont des mesures qui exclut alors il ya
à la fois une nécessité c'est lutter
contre la pollution de l'air ces
quarante mille personnes qui chaque
année dans notre pays 17 40 mille chaque
année donc oui il faut lutter contre la
pollution de l'air par contre il faut
aussi accompagner les français et les
franciliens
quand vous êtes artisan vous n'avez pas
d'autre choix que de prendre votre
véhicule de traverser parfois paris
vous rendre dans un autre département
francilien et donc il faut qu'on vous
accompagne pour faire en sorte que vous
puissiez avoir un véhicule propre et
vous n'avez pas forcément les moyens de
le faire moi j'ai beaucoup de
concitoyens quand ils ont une vieille
voiture c'est pas par plaisir
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens
de la changer et donc là il faut que la
région accompagne on peut pas être dans
une écologique et punitive le fonction
des ans finalement parisse barricades et
puis bah tant pis pour ceux qui habitent
en grande couronne parce que ce cap et
en grande couronne
c'est ceux qui viennent travailler à
paris c'est ce qui permet à paris aussi
d'être la capitale qu'elle est et donc
l'idée c'est de dire bien la région va
venir abonder encore une fois est ce que
l'état fait on est des gens avec des
primes l'achat de véhicules propres mais
la région elle va faire encore plus pour
que vous ayez le moins débourser de
votre poche
comment on finance une telle mesure
justement la région a les moyens la
région un budget d'investissement mais
ça sera pris sur la porte le budget
transport par exemple
alors on a un budget d'investissement
quel 5 milliard d'euros par an donc
c'est quand même un budget qui est très
important en ile-de-france comme la
première région française c'est la
région la plus riche mais la plus
inégalitaire donc avancer des choix
aussi qu'on veut faire de financement il
faut évidemment pas amputer le budget
transport il faut au contraire
évidemment continuer à la renforcer
c'est pour ça qu'on assume aussi de dire
que les propositions d'une partie de la
gauche de dire il faut du tout gratuit
c'est pas réaliste parce que la gratuité
à la fin tout le dialogue bien quelqu'un
qui la paie et on risque malheureusement
de la payer avec des transports qui
seraient moins efficaces moins sûr moins
ponctuels alors qu'on a déjà des
fragilités et puis il faut sur les
transports aller encore plus loin je
pense aux transports à la demande qui
doit être beaucoup plus développé dans
nos territoires ruraux on a encore des
adolescents ont des familles des
personnes âgées qui le week-end n'ont
pas de solution de transport et des
parents qui n'ont pas forcément envie
que leurs enfants ne prennent en scooter
pour pouvoir tout simplement est bien
allé faire ses activités le week-end et
être autonome il faut qu'on puisse avoir
du transport à la demande faut lutter
contre l'isolément des personnes âgées
il faut aussi faciliter l'accès aux gars
et la question des parkings relais
on doit beaucoup plus déployé et la
gratuité probablement aussi de ses
parkings relais que moi je souhaite
pouvoir porter et défendre parce que
c'est un vrai frein pour que les
franciliens et bien acceptent de ne plus
utiliser en permanence leur voiture si
on veut plus utilisé il faut leur donner
des solutions alternatives
en sport sous l'angle sécuritaire aussi
peut-être parce que il ya toujours cette
problématique de sécurité
la présidente sortante a mis en place
plus de 1000 agents pour sécuriser les
transports ce n'est pas suffisant c'est
pas suffisant parce que moi je suis une
femme je vois beaucoup de femmes
renoncent en ile-de-france apprend des
transports en commun parce qu'elles ne
se sentent pas en sécurité dans les
transports en commun je vois des
familles qui ne souhaitent pas que leurs
enfants à certaines heures ou sur
certaines lignes prennent les transports
en commun parce qu'encore une fois ils
ont peur de l'insécurité qui peut s'y
déployer et on le voit bien en ile de
france on a une délinquance qui est plus
en plus jeunes et qui est de plus en
plus mobiles et elle suit en vérité le
parcours des transports c'est la
question des bus on a vu malheureusement
des épisodes dramatiques ces derniers
mois et c'est aussi la question en
général d autres transports en commun
donc ce qu'on veut faire c'est créer une
police régionale et dire encore une fois
l etat les collectivités ça doit jouer
collectif doit travailler ensemble pour
la sécurité des franciliens donc doit
pas continuer à se renvoyer la balle
en dix ans mais qui doit augmenter le
budget ou qui doit augmenter ses
effectifs
la région peut le faire et donc la
région doit le faire pour qu'on ait
enfin une véritable coordination
régionale donné avec une police
régionale qui seraient recrutés par la
région en lien évidemment avec la
préfecture de police
on vient évidemment être les
collectivités locales et leur police
municipale
tout simplement pour qu'on ait une
police régionale qu'ils soient mobiles
comme les la délinquance mais on crée
pas une couche supplémentaire une police
régionale c'est une étape supplémentaire
une couche supplémentaire une strate en
plus alors que la police tout court a
aussi besoin de moyens là on sort de la
question de la région mais vous êtes
aussi député est-ce qu'il faut pas plus
de moyens aux policiers on voit
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont dépassés on l'a
vu pendant le premier mais encore il ya
eu des manifestations et des heurts avec
la police dans les quartiers dans les
yvelines très souvent tous les week-ends
il ya des affrontements avec les jeunes
la police régionale ne va pas solder
tout ça le problème est plus vaste que
ça le problème vous avez tout à fait
raison il est plus vaste la raison pour
laquelle on a depuis 2010 est de manière
systématique
année après année augmenter le budget du
ministère de l'intérieur et augmenter
les recrutements faut être clair ce qui
s'est passé entre 2007 et 2012 pendant
les années de gaulle à sarkozy valérie
pécresse s'est d'ailleurs ministre du
budget à l'époque
il ya eu des baisses drastiques de
budget et les baisses drastiques de
recrutement il ya eu démantèlement des
renseignements territoriaux qui avait
créé bout
toute difficulté notamment dans la
capacité à pouvoir surveiller à pouvoir
enquêter à pouvoir mesurer ce qui se
passe dans nos territoires et on a eu
des baisses d'effectifs
donc là en cinq ans en un quinquennat on
aura recruté dix mille policiers et
gendarmes supplémentaires dans le pays
encore une fois pour les affecter là où
on en a le plus besoin
on aura fait des programmes immobiliers
massif parlons juste à côté le
commissariat d'elancourt on sait que ça
faisait des années et des années qu'on
attendait qu enfin l'état le
gouvernement un gouvernement accepte de
budgéter puisque c'est un budget très
conséquent qu'on ait enfin un nouveau
commissariat digne pour l'ensemble de ce
secteur qui couvre des villes comme
maurepas coignières mais aussi trappe ou
la verrière et bien là on l'a fait donc
oui il faut qu'on continue à augmenter
les moyens pour la police et la
gendarmerie c'est ce qu'on fait en
effective pour leur donner aussi des
moyens dignes d'exercer leur métier
mais il faut aussi que les collectivités
prennent leur part au niveau des
municipalités elles le font
la région l'a en partie fait mais on
peut aller beaucoup plus loin et on doit
aller beaucoup plus loin
une dernière question si votre candidat
et si vous vous êtes amené à siéger à la
région la mesure prioritaire à prendre
pour l'ile-de-france bien moi je crois
que c'est vraiment cette police
régionale parce que la première
préoccupation des franciliens et les
français c'est la question de la
sécurité au quotidien c'est tout
simplement être heureux de vivre en ile
de france avoir envie de vivre en ile de
france avoir envie d'y rester
la première des raisons pour laquelle
vous avez envie d'en partir il ya la
question du logement et à la cherté de
la vie mais c'est d'abord la question de
la délinquance et de l'insécurité
il faut d'abord qu'on règle ce problème
là de manière à ce que chacun se sente
bien tout simplement dans cette région
merci au regard des candidates donc aux
élections régionales en ile-de-france
tête de l'aide dans les têtes de liste
dans les yvelines avec jean-noël barrot
on se retrouve bientôt sur tv 78 radio
sensations
[Musique]